during the past few months the
Bangladeshi government has clamped down
on opposition parties but that didn't
stop tens of thousands of opposition
supporters and people from all walks of
life from taking part in protest rallies
like this one in the capital Dhaka
[Music]
or solidarity with all who are
protesting against this current
government we want Democratic elections
and their caretaker government
many are also angry at the government
for failing to stop sorting energy and
food prices
we are here to demand democracy and
protest against the rising price of
essential food items it's hard for us
working class to make ends meet
security has been tightened across the
capital thousands of
[Music]
African pardoned rallies across the
country and here in Neapolitan in the
capital of Dhaka on Wednesday
main opposition leader fuckral Islam was
just released on Monday after a month in
jail told us a large number of
opposition leaders and activists are
still in jail and says they're living in
inhuman conditions
he has called for the Trump release
our party BNP and as well as 33 other
parties belonging to different goshti or
mochas France they have also announced
that same program that is the 10 point
program for restoration of democracy and
as well as they have also
simultaneously announced a program which
will just go for the reforms of the
state after the election if the election
is at all held under the government
the government though remains defined in
recent months several people have been
shot dead by police hundreds injured and
thousands have been arrested at
opposition rallies across the country
we have been able to meet any challenges
in the past and today under Sheikh
hasina's leadership of armor League
compared to any other time is much
stronger and more united the opposition
Alliance says it will continue to press
home its 10 point demand that includes
the resignation of the government and
the transfer of power to a non-partisan
caretaker Administration before the next
general election convey chaudry Al
Jazeera Dhaka